[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
welcome guys we might be drunk first
guest in the new studio hello
anwar
beautiful beautiful place thank you for
having me thanks for coming you're jews
in the house hell yeah
can you put the apron on for me
i like the apron thank you it makes it
more professional there we go all right
look at that thing it looks like you're
a surgeon in the 20s very brooklyn what
was that clive owens show
the myth the mick did you watch that no
it's the nick the nick the nick was it
good the mick is like an irish slur
that's what i popped in during drinking
yeah uh
yeah was that show good i liked it yeah
he's [ __ ] awesome he's great clive
sexy guy that was my ex's number one
what do you call it a comment not
comment card oh paul
pass he's like a man's man though you
know what i mean like chris hemsworth is
sort of the metro dolphin no hair but
like clive owen
is yeah that's like rugged he's rugged
exactly he could have been like a bond
he's suave but still kind of a dude
he'd be a perfect bond is he handsome
without the context like without the
movie stars
i think he is yeah i mean
but he's cool cool ads he's like the
british clooney
but remember what the bar used to be
like remember tom selleck was the bar
yes that's how muscular you had to be
that was enough right right like magnum
pi shirt off there's no definition but
that was it well is there no definition
pull-up selling look at that he had some
definition he was all right he was
beefier hairy chest healthy dad bod but
the hairy chest i'm really mad that that
went out because right that's nothing
reynolds
ah he's ripped what are you guys talking
about compared to nowadays boy what a
dilf yeah i mean he is pretty that
doesn't cut it today yeah the legs don't
cut it the up top he's all right
man he is a hunk i never really thought
about him he's a hot guy look at this
yeah glowing with the stash that stash
smells like puss
no doubt about my god and good like good
he's more repetitive yeah quality [ __ ]
yeah
yeah
no you know i have a lot of young
reynolds though he's got it too it
wasn't the story with burt reynolds that
he did play girl and he was like all
these all these chicks are gonna are
gonna love me it's just like gay dudes
who read that
i just got like a big gay dude following
i don't know i was gay
i haven't i mean
what women do you think are looking at
this
he was just cool and confident it's all
about the confidence he's [ __ ] around
he's fun i feel like girls say they're
not into chest hair when they're younger
and then they get old enough and then
they realize the truth yeah they're into
it that they're into it i know i've it's
i remember a dated girl very young and
she made she was like please shave your
chest and i'm so mad at myself i did it
and i and i
by the way it lasts for like what three
days and it turns into like little paper
cuts every time she lays on you
so
never again i was young i was insecure
but now women are like oh you're like
you're manly i'm like only in this way i
can't fix [ __ ] right right it's a deep
voice and hairy chest every other way
i'm a [ __ ] coward
well because it sets you apart like not
every guy has that you know what i mean
yeah yeah so i had a lady growing up she
told me to shave because i always had a
little stubble as a kid even she was
like you gotta shave that's gross and
now women love stubble so you're right
you grow into it but they complain about
sometimes when you kiss for a while and
they they get they get red in the face
true from the stuff when they hate it so
they're like shaved but then i i look
weird shaved all the way yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
me too yeah i had a friend he was like
maybe i'm gay maybe i'm gay and he's
like i'm gonna go out and meet a guy i'm
gonna be a gay guy and he went out and
he kissed one guy and he said right when
he felt the stubble he's like i'm not
gay he's like that's what was was the
eye opener there's more there's more
than that separating me from going down
that road but uh ah tried really the
dick stopped me but yeah double i could
handle i yeah i'm just i just there's
more i mean i kissed a boy when i was a
child but whoa i kissed a boy and i
liked it
we're not glossing over this well it's
in my closure
yeah i'll give it away but uh what are
we drinking man i see bodega cat so i'm
excited so bodega cat today we're going
to start with a little sipper a bodega
cat just neat just to enjoy it the way
it is and then we're gonna make a little
bidet cat drink for uh everybody who can
get their hands on at home yeah
so we'll start off with that
not for sale yet
this is me and mark's whiskey oh really
yes whoa you're like uh the breaking bad
guys everywhere
that's when you've made it when you
pivot to alcohol
that makes it makes me excited cause
i've never tried it but you just see the
pictures of them together and you're
like they're friends bro it's weird like
you make the most money doing the thing
that isn't your main thing anymore isn't
that right remember like basketball
you're good at basketball and then shoes
is where they made all the money right
and now if you're an actor like the rock
makes all his money from tequila right
breaking bad away from the movies sure
but it's like
he does the movies so he's big enough to
sell his tequila hey that's so true a
lot of female pop stars make a fragrance
yeah or like rihanna skims
it's all about the other [ __ ] you know
why because you're already a brand so
when you sell the [ __ ] now you make
money on that because yeah there's only
so much money you can make as a human
you have to make a product that people
can try this thing you think of this
this is i love this this i'm proud of
this whiskey cheers cheers
i'm getting there
also booze will ruin your life unless
you get in front of it and sell it
you know you know what i'm saying we
took the beast we're doing both all
right the podcast is not helping our
health here wow
we could die happy
it's really good oh that's good that's
smooth but i'm just saying if you have a
problem with [ __ ]
instead of letting the [ __ ] ruin your
life buy a buy a ranch be a pimp yeah
and flip it around flip it now you're
using the horse yeah so what was the
process of this how did you get your own
so long it's been i want to say 16
months it's been what do you think mark
yeah it's been a while just from idea to
conception we had to design the bottle
we designed the label we picked out the
rye
then it's illegal stuff so it's uh it's
a nightmare
that's pretty baller man but it's coming
it's coming dude
i'm a fan yeah this is [ __ ] good
whiskey bodega it's really nice actually
it's really like a rye rod you know like
very crisp
a little tart
very nice i got the slug line
you've
arrived
all right
we'll throw a little quotation on the
rye
come on
you've been in england too long with
these [ __ ] puns doing that [ __ ]
[ __ ] puns they got me it's like a pun
packet like all right we need eight
pages of puns yes
this is mark mark will say yes to
[ __ ] everything and the problem is he
says yes to everything so without
because we do a pod together they're
like well mark did it i said no they
think you'll do it too any [ __ ] open
mic podcast mark does and i'm like look
i'll do a podcast when i can but you
know we're we're busy i need to write
jokes mark does some random open micro
in like raleigh's podcast and there was
like norman did it well i said no to
kissing that boy that asked
well i me
guilty i had to make it up for him i
haven't noticed that like you're like
the little wayne of comedy oh you just
you feature on every track right is that
a conscious decision where you're like
i'm gonna do everything no it's i can't
say no you ask me to do something i'll
do it sadly kiss that boy yeah i'll do
it all right and uh that's what that's
how i got kevin spacey autograph but uh
no i just i can't say no people ask me i
feel guilty and then sometimes if i have
nothing to do i'm like oh i'll go do
that even though it will help me in no
way and it's a waste of time and all
that but i'll do it huh don't you feel
mad though if you don't have like that's
writing time it's cutting in i know
you're right you're right
so i got i've gotten better i've cut
back you should you should be writing
r-y-e-t-i
there we go right ting writing yeah
that's all the old alcoholics like all
the old sorry all the old writers
used to just drink like fish oh yeah all
the writer's rooms yeah like even snl it
was all fueled by coke back in the day i
keep on hearing yeah yeah that's true
now do you think that's the no they
probably still party
some of them yeah i think it's a
different culture like you can't be that
[ __ ] up uh it doesn't there's too many
talented sober people where people's
threshold for that are like i'll just
get somebody who's sober and can do the
job oh yeah you're right and also back
in the day we didn't have a lot of
therapy like now it's all like health
and wellness and you know work on
yourself and mental health
health and now it's like
all that [ __ ] so you don't need booze as
much
back in the day in baseball like the
players were all drunks and eating
sausages every day yeah and they were
and then guys start doing steroids
you're like well i guess like if i do
the sausage and the beer every day then
i'm like two steps beyond yeah yeah
right right
right like is that what bert says yeah
he's got it he's got it man what is the
definition just like you could do
whatever you want and you'll still
mickey mantle died very young did he
yeah he was like 61 or something pull it
up i mean and then also and then he also
was doing the whole speech like don't be
like me that [ __ ] me up as a kid
because i i grew up watching the yankees
like old documentaries with my grandpa
so oklahoma yeah well 64. all right oh
damn well norm was what 62.
have you seen uh norm's lou gehrig snl
sketch yeah oh i love that so good so
good that's gotta suck to be the guy who
you know you know when you have an
ailment and you go to the doctor like oh
this is called
johnson and whatever syndrome you're
like oh okay at least someone else has
had this but when they're like we're
gonna name this after you
that [ __ ] sucks
you're you're you have the mark norman
disease that's when you can't say no to
any podcast it's like the worst version
of having a sandwich named after you
yeah
one of my favorite curb episodes yeah
they're fighting you ever see that one
did you ever uh white fish in mayo yeah
which i like i like white fish i like
white fish but mayo come on you only
mayo on on fish but that's the salad
that makes it to a fish salad
good point good are you are you a
drinker on the road are you kind of a
little bit like this is fun so when you
guys are like hey we've got these drinks
i'm like yeah yeah but
yeah i'm not first to be like you always
get some drinks but if the occasion
arises i'm down for it
but i never
yeah i'm like a social drinker that's
better you don't want to be an alone
drinker yeah i'm not there yet it looks
cool in the movies but then when you try
you're like this kind of rough no i mean
look i know there's people watching this
having a drink right now you're not
alone we're with you but i do know
like sometimes you're all by yourself i
have like one homework in a game or
something i think we've earned it at our
age
we work hard you go home you have one
high ball you watch tv
i have the full bar at home which i i do
enjoy having i do too yeah i like that i
just went the complete other way i'm
like i don't drink at home i've got a
full bar and uh
i've done it before where i'll have just
like a sad manly like johnny walker and
a cigar just on my patio
that's it that's an elephant
right there
we don't have patio you know what's
crazy just because the way of living in
new york is is so much uh
it's way more like stripped down than
l.a so because i would have these jokes
early on when i would come here
and be like i would [ __ ] on a studio
apartment and then ari shafir was like
oh that's amazing out here like
no one's gonna feel for you if you talk
about your studio apartment that's yeah
and i'm like oh i didn't know about that
yeah yeah he's got a patio by the way
patio sounds like an irish slur oh patio
no yeah he does he has a nice little
patio but it's uh yeah studios here are
like solid yeah you know
but in l.a yeah l.a look we'll give it
to you you got the weather and you got
the space but
you you don't like look when you start
out there's some la people out there if
something's tough about the city like it
feels like everyone went there to make
it you're like one of the few guys where
i'm like since i've known you it's been
a while even though i feel like we've
never like sat down and had like a long
conversation but like
i'm like oh [ __ ] he's like a pure comic
oh you're great that's nice
well that's super nice um i remember one
time you know amy hawthorne yeah sure so
i knew her from comedy i knew her from
the comedy store because she would come
around there early on and i knew her for
years and then she went to new york and
when she was visiting after being out
here for a long time
she's like oh yeah i was talking
somehow like new york versus la comics
came up and then
and then i think i came up and then she
goes oh yeah norman said he doesn't
count like he's different and that meant
a lot to me just uh to kind of have that
new york badge or to be like oh he's
he's not exactly like an lala comic so
do you think we're snobby or do you
think you guys are snappier
i think i i think well cause you guys
are comedy pure like your jokes first
and i'm very much jokes first like i
love
i love that uh you know at its core
jokes are everything to me yeah so
you're like joke guys and i i love that
you're a joke guy but you will do
amazing act out from like i'll watch you
do [ __ ] i mean there's even a joke in
your new special hat trick which is
streaming on youtube right now check it
out uh and three there's three rooms in
the comedy store kind of like the seller
yep the three rooms and you did a
special
in each each room yeah great concept and
yeah it's never been done right you know
yeah so there's the original room the
main room and then the belly room
upstairs and yeah no one's done that at
the comedy store
but some like one guy's like ray romano
did this and i'm like
i know i'm the first at the comedy store
i'm not i don't have the concept of like
doing three different mics somewhere
right but the guy's like race did this i
go yeah he did that like also i got a
great idea about a show where everybody
loves me
dude everybody's done every some
variation yeah romano by the way the
nicest dude in comedy yeah
he's like the only dude like when we'd
start out when a famous guy would pop
into the cellar they'd always like bump
you but he would be like do you mind if
i do like i'll go on after you like he
was so
nervous to inconvenience anyone i'm like
i've never seen a famous dude like that
because he doesn't have to do that yeah
so it kind of goes a little extra mile
like oh man this guy's so famous and he
still kind of
knows the comic rules yeah what are we
drinking
so i guess we'll call this one the
bodega vaccine
i like it uh the deadly omicron um
and basically it's like a little spin on
uh uh penicillin wait a minute he can't
have your anti-vaxx
no you can't drink it oh yeah i can't
have this but just uh just a little
honey ginger lemon syrup with uh our
famous bodega cat rat it's a penicillin
basically essentially it's really good
these are classics yeah i love the
little ginger candy in there [ __ ] oh
that's good you always gotta have a
little ginger candy especially if you're
like a big drinker like um ginger is
always like really nice because you
don't want anything too sweet so that
little like spice yeah
yeah ginger is fantastic especially with
a rye that's something light
you know when it when it's like heavy
and dark it's a little too much but with
a ride rides finally a vaccine i'd have
to go to staten island together this is
great
also the third
irish slur they're ginger in there
so we're on a roll
nick patio ginger
so
you have a joke i'm talking about like
act outs because you are hard jokes but
then you'll do act out so you do a cobra
kayak down the mass shooting joke yeah
you know where you kind of just say like
these kids just learn karate instead of
shooting up a school and we're supposed
to believe that and then he does the
whole like miyagi doe i can't do it but
it's like yeah it was like your kid gets
bullied in high school he comes home he
sees his dad's ar-15 and he goes that's
the coward's way out
he starts doing all this [ __ ]
such a it's like timely on so many
levels it's perfect
that's the way i view act outs though i
like
because there was this younger comic one
time and he he liked act outs and stuff
and he would do them
but i always say you got to earn the act
out yeah so it's like joke first and
then that [ __ ] is just seasoning on the
already kind of like tight joke yeah
the tag yes the act outs are kind of
tags right um but if you're like on
stage
pretending you're in a hang glider or
something i could tell when you're like
oh you just wanted to act like you were
in a hangout exactly i saw guys like
that early on they were great at sound
effects and this guy i'm like he'd just
be doing like a siren i'm like there's
not even a [ __ ] joke you just want to
show us you could do a siren yeah it's
like impressions they put beatboxing in
you're like that's not a bit you ever
the the guys who do the uh impressions
and there's no it's just the impression
right this is uh jack nicholson meeting
christopher walken and then you see a
guy who do impressions and there's a
joke and you're like oh that was you
like you said this double win yeah yeah
yeah so i always say like earn the act
out yeah we've all seen the guy too this
is why i don't do act outs i think i did
that one time in 1988 i did a pratfall
and it didn't get a laugh you did a
breadfall i did one in like a classroom
or something and i was like cause i was
a zinger guy and then i try to you know
oh i'll do this fall down thing and no
one laughed and i was like i'll never do
and act out again because when you give
and like hurt yourself and do a whole
thing to silence
i've always felt that too just the delta
between how much you give and if you're
getting nothing that's that makes it
exponentially sadder the worst whereas
if you're just like throwing a word out
there like did you do that at open mics
because i mean you need you do need some
energy from a crowd to commit to [ __ ]
like that
and you're saying like it almost feels
like dishonest like you don't realize
you're not doing well if you're doing
something that hardcore for a crowd that
gives you nothing true yeah right so was
that hard as hell to do with mike's
there's dials on it so like even though
i have an act now if it's rip and
roaring i'll stay in the pocket and do
be more physical but if it's a bar show
and it's kind of more chill the worst
it'll be kind of a toned down version of
the act out right yeah so you kind of
give what you get
right so i'm not going to be doing the
running man for two people and like
sweating because that just looks so sad
yeah and yeah you can move you're a good
move i was at a party once and i saw you
in the distance dancing what party was
this where was i i don't know maybe i
was jerking off but or it was a wet
dream but you can dance for a comic i
think i'm okay oh no you got it you've
got movies
i've seen the instagram yeah yeah i was
at the same party also jerking off
yeah thanks i appreciate it it's nice
i mean you can dance so i think when you
at you do act out it's like you actually
commit you you know this thing if i do
it it would look silly and dumb but you
you actually
doing it that's nice sometimes a comic
if you never do it and then you that's
true too like i remember nick apollo on
like an early album did like a sound
effect and it killed so hard because
they were like this guy does sound
effects style change ian edwards is like
that too he's so chill and he's like a
brilliant writer and he's so like
measured and has great jokes but
sometimes he'll do an act out and i i
love that [ __ ] because yeah that's my
jam
so it it'll hit even harder because he
doesn't do that a lot so who's one of
your guys coming up where you're like
this is what i want to be
comic wise like when i was coming up
i mean what i was like stand-up was
never really on my radar when i was
super young but delirious put it on the
map for me
when i saw that i was like i could see
that eddie murphy yeah great jokes great
and it was everything um because prior
to that my comedy knowledge was informed
by like the simpsons
yeah because i watched that when i was a
kid but there's so many brilliant
writers and comedians who who were like
a part of that show that like what a
great blueprint you know yeah that and
snl and then delirious came along and uh
and i researched how people got an snl
and it was improv or stand up and then i
researched second city and like
groundlings and you have to pay money
and then my parents are from afghanistan
they it would be like clown college they
wouldn't be cool with me simpsons
episode though what like college yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's right
yeah so stand up just seemed more doable
because you're out there on your own you
don't pay money
so that's why i chose the stand-up path
it's also the curse of stand-up because
now every tom dick and harry is like
i'll do that that'll be my thing then
they have a photo of them on facebook
with a microphone and they put stand up
in their bio and the rest is history
yeah yeah but that's why also when you
can you can kind of figure it out and
and it's working for you it's kind of
extra cool because anyone could just
true true yeah yeah and i do like you
you kind of get what you put into it you
don't you're not reliant on a team yeah
you're not reliant on
uh you know someone saying you're
graduated to the next level you're not
forking over money yes it's uh it's like
golf yeah yeah yeah golf tennis any
sport where he's like working on you
yeah i mean you're right like team
sports sometimes you see like these
great nba players or something and
they're just like you're like well he
never won one account i'm like yeah well
it's a team sport though yeah you know
you can make your team better but if you
don't have the people around you yeah it
sucks to
you know to
you know live and die on other people
i know i hate it yeah hey it's a lot of
work like you ever done an improv troupe
no back in the day yeah yeah i did one
and it's it's really you to be there on
time hang out together be together write
together like do stuff together it's a
lot didn't you do a sketch thing you had
a sketch special too oh go face yeah
yeah that was like our because we would
do both we were um we were using that
with you it was uh hassan minhaj wow and
aristotle who's on snl now wow what
happened awesome get [ __ ] i know you
know what's with us it's kind of
confirming though because i think we
were too early
um like we were putting out some nice
youtube sketch we're doing it for two
years
and
just the industry didn't really they
didn't get it or yeah they weren't
really about it
and then and then hudson gets daily show
and like aristotle's snl now and ossif
is in that new harry styles and florence
pew movie wow so like everyone is doing
pretty well and it's nice to look at
that poster and be like oh man everyone
is on their rocket ship already so we
weren't crazy yeah yeah i mean
definitely i mean the industry gets it
so [ __ ] wrong it's well you guys are
prime examples of that and i know like
we don't get to spend enough time
because we're on different coasts but
when i was in la and watching your guys
trajectory it was really inspiring
because
you're like oh there's a different way
it's weird right i mean we were nervous
as hell doing i remember comics i really
respected being like you put out a free
youtube special you're a [ __ ] idiot i
remember hearing oh saying and even now
you know you're like oh thank god i did
that people used to laugh they'd be like
you can see this next comic on youtube
and the guy was like hey get away my
uncle's on youtube yeah it was [ __ ]
it was i remember that would get a laugh
like they thought they were zinging me
yeah the host it was hilarious i mean
even bill burke talked about when he put
his thing on netflix his first special
on netflix whatever that was he was like
what is this i'll give it a shot [ __ ] it
let's see what happens and it obviously
worked out but even that was new and
weird what i've realized about stand-up
is these these ways to pop
they come and go yeah like whatever the
platforms are but if you if you are a
stand-up and your ship is moving in the
right direction
the names change
like it'll be it'll be comedy central
for a couple years then it's netflix for
a couple years hbo and then maybe yeah
there was hbo before that and then now
it's youtube and it'll be something else
but so long as you are continuing to
grow in your craft
that [ __ ] doesn't matter right
because the new thing will come along
and they'll just look at who's where is
everybody in the pantheon of comedy
right now yes and we go okay we'll just
choose from what i've noticed all those
things you name netflix they all kind of
somehow end up on youtube at the end of
the day
i noticed that with late night uh like
the tonight show and everything right
and that was such a tune in you do it
late nights and now you get like
maybe one tweet you guys love them
though right you still do them huh you
just did a cold call cordon yeah what do
you want to do
you put a set together it's exciting
it's a it's a tight rope you can't [ __ ]
up yeah i don't know how many more i'm
gonna do but i like i mean how many more
can you actually do i feel like all
these shows are going off the air yeah
and everybody's like everybody's
starting podcasts also doesn't kimmel
tape his in vegas i'm like doesn't that
eliminate the purpose of doing i know a
late night you're like i'm doing it to
be in the building to feel like i'm in
show business they send you to vegas
yeah i don't want to go to vegas for any
reason yeah i'm doing colbert it shoots
in tampa
[Laughter]
yeah what's your mindset when you do
late nights now um i'm wondering do you
get notes or have you done it so many
times they just let you do whatever
they're pretty when i did cordon this
time they were pretty much like i
remember i had one joke it's funny when
they give you notes my closer was a joke
about taking a finger in the butt
and they were like you can't say but you
have to just say in that spot and i'm
like sure what it's almost like it's
almost more fun at that point where
you're like let me [ __ ] let me elude
do you almost feel like you're carson
you know you almost feel like you're
doing like a sex joke in the 80s you're
like [ __ ] it let me give it a try as
long as it still hits and i tried it on
stage and still killed the same so i was
like yeah maybe it's not about the the
butt thing but just sounds funnier than
in that spot in the butt but it's also
weird when you have you've been doing it
a certain way for so long and they go
can you do this
and you have to unprogram your your mind
in like the last second totally and it's
weird cause these shows are like comedy
shows they all they're all about being
funny but then they're like could you be
less funny right here
do this less funny you're like ah this
this is how it works i know but you
gotta do it this way like all right so
i'll be you wouldn't do that with sports
you know how you shoot from here and yo
it always goes in
shoot up shoot from the locker room and
uh you know we'll see what happens
yeah no it's it's annoying though that
so that's the thing is when i i remember
doing a foul one the amount of notes
they gave me i was just like i don't
want to do that i don't this is i'm fine
yeah yeah chris d turned on a fallon
because they wouldn't let him do an
accent and he's like my wife and
daughter puerto rican yeah i got to do
their accent they're like yeah it's kind
of offensive why he that's why he
married puerto rico
he's like i want to do this voice i
think he's a trans friend for that
reason as well
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah when you weigh it now it makes less
sense because if you're putting all
these
like handcuffs on you to do a late night
set and it doesn't move the needle as
much as it did back in the day you're
like why don't i just put this clip on
youtube i know there's more rules and
less traction i mean yeah it's
interesting like they
good t-shirt yeah more rules less
traction ky jelly
more traction i guess
i messed that one up but you know it's
uh
it is weird when you get those notes and
you're just like but this doesn't but
then you'll get like a publicist who's
like no it's like it's important it's a
good look and you're like good luck you
know what's a good look is selling out
on the road totally how do you guys feel
about publicist did you hire like a
traditional media because i think i
think things are shifting where it's way
more important to like have somebody who
knows the digital space more than
anything yes because someone's like hey
we're going to do a vulture article like
who cares but if you know instagram
algorithms or tick tock algorithms
that's way more valuable you need a
hacker more than a publicist totally i
need like a russian bot spy or something
you need like a 12 year old who just
knows the trending hashtags and dances
and [ __ ] so true i i had a tick tock and
i i'm stuck at all that stuff and it had
15 000 followers and somebody hit me up
like this is crazy you have this many on
instagram this being on youtube how do
you have such a low tick there i was
like i don't know and he's like i think
he should tear it all down and let me do
it i was like go for it and now it has
like 300 something thousand in no time
because of this kid he just knows what
to do yeah it's all the same videos it's
fascinating he resized one he changed
the banner
popped yeah you need somebody who who
like understands that space yeah um
i have to find that person like because
i was toiling over the special i go do i
hire a because for my first one that i
did on cso i had a traditional pr guy
yeah were you able to were you able to
re-release it on youtube all right i
know r.i.p so so cso was like peacock
before peacock which is so sad yeah yeah
it was peacock 1.0 so
you know how hot peacock is nowadays
this is the first iteration of it
that's crazy they got you who else did
they get stanhope joey wow these are
like big names they had some real people
it was a thing for everybody but you
know like look even when i did it i knew
no one was gonna see it but i knew it
was a stepping stone special
um i knew that i would at least get to
put this out there it would look
beautiful
um i would get to at least artistically
put the thing out there yeah and then
eventually when cecil went under
i think comedy dynamics they licensed it
to comedy central so it's on their
youtube now oh that's good so at least i
have two specials that are accessible on
youtube now so it worked out in that way
but nobody saw it when it came out wow
that must be heartbreaking i i had that
i remember
the stefano and i had a similar thing we
were talking because we had a special on
uh on it was on comedy central back in
the day and norman did the same thing
with the hours special on comedy central
and we're being like wow this is amazing
it looks amazing the same [ __ ] like i'm
proud of this special and then you go on
the road and you're like
looks pretty similar to last week
you know so that's that's a bummer when
you when when that happens when you
catch the things a little too late
yeah yeah i know what you mean i i
remember i got on guy code like towards
the end
where it was great if you if you got
there in the sweet spot you know of
course i was in there like the last year
i got in the ace of base the band like a
week ago so
i'm just doing the weird raps
i want to be with you
that's uh that's crazy so you i didn't
know you were on that yeah i see so did
it help me
i got a hoodie out of it
you know enough time has passed where
it's not as sad when i wear the hoodie
now it's kind of cool right oh [ __ ] a
siso hoodie nice yes it's like cbgb
totally and i'm further enough in my
career or it's a nice throwback yeah
whereas after it happened it's still
kind of stung a bit cause cso is it's
like quibbier you know i saw a guy
wearing a letterman uh letter jacket and
i was like that's pretty cool it's like
vintage an actual letterman jacket yes
that's that's there you go damn that's
uh
is this the thing that you feel like i
saw it's got a ton of views in a short
amount of time do you feel like this is
the thing that's been the biggest the so
far especially yeah kind of yeah i think
uh
because the cecil thing that comedy
central put out on their youtube it was
already a few years removed and it was
kind of unceremonious right so like it's
cool it's accessible but it's almost me
from years ago it's not very immediate
this has been a great little
lightning rod moment an introduction to
me that some people may not know my
stand-up
cause like i'm not super present on
podcasts or i don't have a ton of stuff
out there like do you hate doing
podcasts no you know it's kind of
inspiring just the the control you get
to have yes
[ __ ] these industries back in the day
you you had to yeah that's a good
website sorry thanks
you had to get on sitcoms and [ __ ] you
know yeah yeah
you were hoping to be six on the call
sheet on some tgif sitcom to pull some
ticket sales but no one watches tv
anymore right and people are really
savvy like it's cool that comedy fans
are super surgical with
what they tune in on they don't watch a
show
that guy's good i'll go catch him on the
weekend
they love stand up yeah yeah you should
just watch what was on now you find your
own [ __ ] you meet up with people they're
like are you watching this you're like
i've never heard of that they're like it
has 400 million views you're like i
didn't know but that you can just find
stuff there's so many avenues yeah i saw
someone trolling stavros
on on twitter being like if he was a
good special wouldn't be on youtube and
you just want to be like you know
nothing about comedy you're way better
and also like how you digging a guy like
that's the funny thing about youtube is
probably the best avenue right now even
of even netflix is
even better because
you can just click that [ __ ] link
anyone when i was thinking about what to
do with this special i just knew you
know i'm at a point in my career where i
can't afford to have people not find it
i needed to make it as frictionless as
possible yes i needed to be able to do a
punch yeah i needed to be able to do a
pod hyperlink or tweet hyperlink ig
stories swipe up
because twitter bio yes that's where i'm
at right now like when you haven't
broken yet and nobody knows who you are
it's way more valuable for people to be
able to
like access it also
we've talked about this but like the
louis method is great if you're huge
already but also you know where people
you people that don't know you pay what
five or ten dollars for the special but
you're not really getting new fans when
you do that [ __ ] yeah cause no one's no
one's taken a chance spending money on
things
i mean look i'll rent a movie
if it's if it's a good movie but i feel
like most people don't do that [ __ ] no
no it's gotta be a hard word of mouth
hard like you gotta see this totally i
think comedy is moving we've always been
kind of adjacent to music and indie
bands but i think with the way the
models are going with podcasting and
specials on youtube it's becoming more
and more like indie bands
where i think
it's cool if there's a comic that you
like you know if you're someone out
there and people aren't hip to it yet
like oh this guy's like you know it's
like a modest mouse or something before
they break yeah it's cool to be in the
know yeah because it's that accessible
now
i see that in my crowds i'll see someone
wearing one of mark's comedy shirts and
i'm just like god this is so stupid this
is so stupid that people just buy sure
it's funny to me it's like it's weird i
i love it you know yeah they're on my
website
but now that's gonna sound
offensive please bear with me later on
anwar but
i think
being so
honky looking has hurt you
um because we all know you're hilarious
comics will share like joe listen like
have you seen this and it's a video of
you doing a sketch or something i'm like
this is hilarious
your your your stand-up is good your
sketches are good you're a good-looking
guy a hell of a dancer you're young
you've done all the stuff you live in la
you've been on rogan you've been on this
you've been on that
i think you should be bigger well that's
don't you yes that's flattering well
it's not my place to say where i should
be you know it's a hard question but i
think if you looked more ethnic i bet
you'd be bigger
you know i i will
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i've thought about it i think i do fall
in this weird like racial no man's land
well these [ __ ] in the uh the board
room sorry to cut you off there
they're so full of [ __ ] they're like we
need diversity first of all the whole
room is a bunch of white guys secondly
they're like hey you're not hispanic
enough
you know to some hispanic guy some
mexican guy like we're looking for like
you know a stereotype so like so you're
a dick he's he's he's mexican and you're
like you're not mexican enough though
yeah and that's what i'm talking about
you're kind of nailing it on the head
thank you there's this thing because
it's been my my experience you know just
being in hollywood and stuff that uh
there are these diversity opportunities
yeah but but it's if with it's if you're
within this certain band of of course
you have to be uh using that yes as like
your weapon but if you're using that
you're kind of a lazy comic because by
the way they agree by the way they mean
using it it's like a lot of those like
ethnic stereotypes that you're leaning
on a lot of times and you don't lean on
those yeah i i i feel like mencia was a
guy where they were you know whatever
but i mean he was a dude that was like
that was his whole persona he changed
his name to sound more hispanics right
there you go i'm very american you know
my parents are from afghanistan i was
born in syria yeah your last name is
wholeness it was homeless yes i'm
cousins
but i'm very american i grew up very i
have american comedy sensibilities i
always i just i like funny first and
identity second it's not a and so if i
go in and i want to pitch like a
workplace comedy or something they're
like well we can get that from a white
guy
we brought you in because we wanna
it was your mom like in a killing field
or something in afghanistan like can we
talk about it like one way a great setup
for a comedy
killing field
yeah hilarious
it's a good title
but it's like they want you to be
diverse in the way they want you to be
diverse so it's like this liberal racism
kind of yeah of course
and that's a lot of hollywood and that's
i think
i think that's part of the rise of
youtube is that they were making what
they made felt very insincere yeah and
that's why all these youtube specials
really started to
pop up i think yeah i think they never
the industry never really gave america
enough credit um because i think they
would have blueprints they just want to
make money it's like the stock market so
they only know what's come before in
these trends so they go okay we know
what this will get a return on this
but if you see a guy like me i'm afghan
kind of ethnically ambiguous there's no
data points as to like we'll get a
return on investment right right because
you're looking at everything but funny
like funny is secondary you got that
right yeah but what's great about
youtube and just straight to the people
is
they don't really care about that [ __ ]
they kind of just want to be entertained
and word of mouth is everything like if
something's funny people will share it
like i don't you feel good sharing
something good like if i see a good
movie i'm like dude you got to watch
this movie it's great like people want
to share stuff yeah especially now with
so much content there's so many movies
there's 18 networks you know there's
hulu there's amazon there's apple
there's netflix's whatever
so you gotta hone in because there's so
much trash i mean how many times can you
watch the british bake off you know how
many times you watch is it cake so when
you find something good you got it don't
drag the is it cake oh [ __ ] we got a
cake lover oh hold on this isn't a real
microphone let me slice this
the whole time what a great reveal a
beer jew we just got him
dude you know uh
it's so true but
it is you know
it is tough
to i mean you make a good thing i think
people will find it and also when you're
on youtube i feel like the audience like
they they feel like part of like it's
like an underdog story it's kind of cool
they're like well this didn't get made
it's funny that some people feel shame
in that because i'm like no i think it's
really cool that you self-release stuff
and i know some great comics have hold
held onto material for too long because
they don't maybe there's a fear in
like you you hit me and mark up before
and asked about like should i put it on
someone else's channel should i put it
on mine it seems like you're happy you
put it on yours totally yeah yeah cause
you're gonna have to have that [ __ ] at
some point anyway you may as well get
the well things like we talked about
before where the labels change on
whatever the hot platform is at the time
but what's cool about putting it on your
own channel is like
as long as i'm alive i'm here to stay so
i get to build the channel and i can
continue to put more stuff on my so
you're kind of reinvesting in yourself
yes rather than making this cool thing
and giving it to a conglomerate who had
nothing to do with it hoping to get a
little more views but it's not even
promised it's kind of it's short money
that like i just wanted i want to get it
out i want a lot of money i wanted
people to see it which i get but you got
to build something and have because i
think eventually
comedy and tv and all that will be your
channel like
faheem's youtube page will be like
tbs in the future and i'll watch your
page i'll watch your page i'll watch
that but that's what tv is going to
become i don't think it's going to be
these networks maybe those will always
be there but i think it's going to be
very specific in the future
we do a podcast like you got this
podcast you just listen to the radio
yeah people just kind of subscribe to
whatever they want so it all comes into
one channel
there you go perfect
yes i want that butthole
not these other ones i want this lady's
[ __ ] are you are you are you getting
a lot of messages online about this yeah
it's got a lot of views in a short
amount of time it's really cool because
uh you're too close to it you know when
you do it like a special you've seen it
a million times you've been in editing
it doesn't hit you like
like an average audience member you know
because you're just too close to it so
it's cool to
see it from the the response of other
people like yeah yeah it's been great
and i think they appreciate because my
goal with this was
i didn't want the glitz and the glam i
just wanted to throw back to i wanted to
capture i wanted to capture rather than
recreate
you know because when we do special
sometimes it's it's sort of like you've
built all these jokes yeah and then it's
a celebration of the material but people
know it's being filmed right i wanted
this just to be a fly on the wall
experience at the store like it's a
regular night of operation oh really no
one knows like they don't know there's
cameras and stuff
yeah so
there's no artifice there's no
there's no big to-do yes we've all seen
those specials where you do one line and
everybody's like
yeah all right come on yeah i wanted it
to feel kind of real and honest um and i
think some people have responded to that
and they they can tell they go oh this
is cool it's just raw it's not like
we're trying to pull something over you
it's just take the lens cap off and
totally yeah good on you man how do you
i mean now he's he just recorded a
special nice now you just put one out
what's your thing because you do the
road a little bit yeah yeah i'll pop out
every now and then what about new
material what's your move
like how i build how you got to build
and then if they saw that so they see
this they come out and see you
you don't want to give them that again
no of course not yeah does it stress you
out uh well i don't have a ton of dates
lined up i'm gonna i may i might have i
always call it yeast you have maybe 15
minutes of yeast to build the rest of
your new hour yeah right
so
i'll be building at the comedy store and
just places around l.a
get it to a nice place and then probably
go on tour with some stuff that's not
from this
okay you guys how do you guys do it
i got an infection no i don't have i
don't have much
i need more uh
i need uh i have ideas there's always
ideas but yeah i mean i burned a lot
because you know you also want to put
out
the best possible special you can put
out so it's tough you know how much do
you save
yeah i i wish i had more new stuff to go
off but at the same time like you know
pressure's good i mean it is it is good
to be like [ __ ] i need stuff uh i am
nervous
some of those seller spots where you're
following some new young comic who's
just murdering and you're like here goes
nothing but i'll tell you like how often
i watch like a legend like colin quinn
just go up there and and i'm like man he
really has ideas even when it's not
hitting really they're so rich and
they're so like he's quinn is someone
i've like totally copied and like
preparation like he would do the fat
black [ __ ] cat side room run his hour
and i was like i didn't see anyone else
doing that so i remember asking liz at
the seller i'm like can i start doing
hours in there so that's how i would
build my hours by literally just copying
quinn's method cause i'm like he's one
of the best ever the best let's do what
quinn does yeah and still got great
ideas i opened for him i don't know this
is probably four months ago now but i
was in awe i was watching his set and i
was like
this is brilliant this is all like
special worthy [ __ ] and he hasn't even
put any of it out yet and it was all new
and he's on another level but i usually
build because it's most of the spots
around la are 15 minutes so
which is tough right i mean it's like
what just i mean it's tough to write a
new act and because i you feel guilty i
think when it's a short set just doing
all new [ __ ] well yeah i like i wouldn't
do an entire set of 15 new so i'll slide
in maybe a few jokes
that's the move yeah you slide in a few
it depends what type of show you're
doing if it's like a younger comics bar
show or something and you're doing it
for free that's kind of free reign to do
for whatever you want yeah um but yeah i
kind of traditionally build in little 15
minute increments around la and then
take it on the road do you guys build on
the road
i do mostly on the road
what i like to do a lot is i'll i'll do
it like a you know a long setting of a
good show and then at the end i'll be
like hey can i do new [ __ ] that's
awesome
that way i'm kind of like i've proven
i'm like i've given you a good show and
i kind of
sell it as hey
uh i'd like to come back here with a new
hour so i'm kind of being like i'm doing
this so i don't you know turn to a lazy
[ __ ] comic so usually they're
incredibly supportive sometimes when a
joke bombs it's funny i mean it's like
when you set it up like that i know some
comments will just sneak it in to see if
it fits but i like to really i mean i do
it sometimes but also i do like on the
road when you're first in those in the
fetal stages i i like doing that that's
a good move because they they're a
little more giving maybe or
are forgiving yeah well and you've
already given them a great show yeah
this is just like dvd extras
right so they're stoked they get a
window into the process like oh cool
he's trying out some jokes and a bad
joke is is it we'll get a laugh
sometimes because they'll be like oh
that one wasn't there it is a funny
moment to have with each other of course
and you go i know that was bad they go
it was it was [ __ ] bad that's a great
moment what i've been doing in la i've
started this show just to work on new
material called
fahim works on stuff and his friends
drop by so i emc it and i'll do five
minutes of new stuff in between but i
have my friends
uh i'll do it like in the belly room um
so it's like 80 c it's super low low key
and i don't have the burden of
bringing the heat like because they're
going to get some great comedy as i
bring them up and it's an opportunity
for fans of mine to kind of see me
working on new stuff who uh who like
what kind of comics are popping in
i'm trying to think like jesus trejo did
it one time uh kirk foxx oh good jokes
good one yeah ian ian edwards
who uh like when you started at the
store in l.a who were your favorite guy
who were guys that you were watching
there that you were like oh this guy is
pushing me to write this dude's [ __ ]
awesome or like maybe an older guy who
like that maybe took you helped out a
little bit uh and you've seen oh sorry
oh no not at all you've seen the store
and all these different uh totally these
different iterations and timelines um
like we just got past the juggernaut
years which i call right
right where every star came back and the
lineups were [ __ ] insane yeah the
avengers every every night right
um and now it's this post pandemic it's
still cool and it's a lot of the shows
are sold out yeah this is like the first
half of end game
yeah people getting back together
um
bobby was always great bobby lee yeah
he's always really um we got to get him
on this
yeah he's amazing he's a great pods all
about paying it forward and he's just
wise he knows the comedy game and
would take like he i think he's one of
the first guys to take me on the road
with him oh nice yeah
yeah giving advice and stuff neil
brennan is a guy too just love neil
brilliant joke writer just so [ __ ]
sharp yeah um yeah his his some of his
jokes i love his bit and his half hour
special where he's talking a lot of good
jokes you can't even you can't even
compliment a woman anymore you know the
yeah me too joke he's like yeah that was
your problem giving women compliments
i love his bit about uh he's like women
their bodies are so amazing if you were
an architect you know it's like big tits
big ass small ways tiny feet if you're
an architect be like it's not safe
that is such a great line yeah he's you
know what he's good at too is like he'll
do men versus women bits in ways i'm
like oh i've never heard that angle
which is yeah a lot of times people will
think when you think something's going
to be hacky in the setup and then you're
wowed in the punchline it's almost even
cooler yeah not that i think his jokes
are going to be hacky but like a setup
where you're like oh i've heard a lot of
men versus women bits yes but when it's
done well you're like oh
yeah yeah he's good kind of like a
whiskey you think you've had them all
and then one day bodega catches you're
here and blows your mind
not hacking oh yeah that was smooth
[Laughter]
neil yeah bobby yeah sebastian burr
would come by billboard wow yeah it's
amazing he's one of my favorites
sebastian's a guy i just saw him at the
garden we talked about it but i was
never like a sebastian guy you know i
like a tell i like a little gritty uh i
like a guy who talks about his dick or a
funny lady but sebastian was always like
oh that's one of those
um bigger comics and uh it never grabbed
me and i saw him live and i was like
this is a great show yeah this is
amazing i have a theory when it comes to
maybe performance style of new york
performance style of new york versus la
i always thought about the actual um
like theater space when you do stand up
in new york it's
the real estate is very
limiting here so it's like a small stage
there's not a lot of room to play it's
like a goldfish yeah so in l.a there's
the stages are bigger you die very young
here's what mark means
so you may be more apt to explore the
space in l.a because you're not people
on people whereas in new york you're
kind of on a milk crate yeah mike's here
so interesting you don't even think
because you're in a cage a little bit i
like it i like it in cages yeah i mean
that's
we uh
that's i've never heard it like that
that's well said i mean it's uh
something about new york too is uh
we do too many sets here sometimes i
think like mark and i think almost like
la's more spread out in new york
sometimes you can do like four or five
sets a night and sometimes i don't think
it's benefiting me sometimes i think i'm
just like
because it makes you
i've always said there's you have to
walk that line between like hating your
new material so you're doing new [ __ ]
but you can't hate it so much so you're
just like all right here let me plow
through this [ __ ] again right you don't
want to feel like
that about the jokes at the same time
sure the audience knows when you've
fallen out of love with a bit they know
even if it's a great bit if you're not
in it anymore your heart's not into it
they can sniff it they just know you
don't care about this joke anymore it's
crazy like a joke will just stop working
yeah weird when you're like this joke
works and then it's just you listen to
all recordings you're like what what's
different i know but they just know your
soul's not selling it anymore right you
can even have that with with newer
material where like wow that new joke
just [ __ ] murdered and then you do it
a week later and it bombs it's like you
didn't have that same spark yeah when
you think of a new joke it's like
exciting and
you know fun that goes away i didn't
know you were a seattle guy i didn't
know okay so are you are you are you a
hoops fan are you pissed
yeah i mean it sucks we have no team and
we've had no team for this long yeah um
yeah i wonder when we'll get another one
but yeah i grew up in that era gary
payton sean camp griffey it was a really
nice moment did you know what's going on
here
ken griffey jr come on the biggest
morning i've ever seen oh beautiful i
remember those old sports center ads
when they're just doing the same it must
be a homer because the pitcher just said
doe
those old those old sports centers
those were great remember um when he
turned his hat backwards for the home
run derby and everyone was like
he's a thug or that was the big one in
the 90s we're like oh my god he's
turning his hat backwards i thought it
was like the coolest thing i've ever
seen ah i was like don't you guys this
that's like old baseball heads too
you're like do you realize this is like
good for the game i know right what i
like about baseball is that they have a
very relaxed chain policy yeah
like nothing is true no other like that
looks like it's 40 pounds are you sure
you want to run the bases with the thing
though flavor flavors got a full
clock i also love that it's the last
sport where you have a belt
oh yeah like technology has come
you don't need a belt but they go no
we're not going to lose the belt good
point you're right
oh dude i guess boxers get a belt
he was one of the coolest players ever
yeah he literally was the michael jordan
of baseball oh for sure they got injured
i remember he got injured i don't know
if we have the footage of it because
baseball's so [ __ ] lame about sharing
footage which is probably why the league
is shrunk in popularity suffering but
you know he broke his arm jumping up to
catch a ball into the wall i remember
that yeah i mean look at that [ __ ] oh
he's going full speed and he he gets the
cash but he breaks his [ __ ] wow what
a story what's sad is when i look at old
clips from my childhood and they're all
in 360p
or like oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
like there's no high def i know
oh dude if i want to watch a sean camp
highlight reel it's going to be grainy i
got one for you the last time the knicks
won a championship was in black and
white
[Laughter]
yeah my dad used to oh
he hit that hard
that's badass wait a minute
i can't even see the ball yeah he broke
his wrist and that one oh poor guy
because he knows his career's turning
remember randy johnson that guy would
throw like 102. yeah man we had a lot of
great players that era i won't go two
sports hard you see that clip where he
threw a fastball into like a goose dude
yes he's blew it up that was great crazy
peter hated that [ __ ]
uh i'd talk about getting old i remember
having eight million vhs tapes
selling them
on like ebay or something then i had
eight million dvds and selling them so
i've gone now it's all digital but i've
gone like
multiple
platforms of i got amazon i got amazon
downloads who wants to buy it i got
blu-ray you name it oh there's the
pigeon that used to be like a power move
on cribs remember
oh
come on the timing how cool would that
be if that bird was trying to kill
himself and he was like this is how i'll
do it i will wait to the big world
series game
what a way to go out huh oh
that's poetic you know what's crazy
players get hit by balls that fast and
they just do this
yeah that's all they do good one of the
guys blew up and just this one
oh [ __ ] that was a fast ball holy [ __ ]
a-rod turned into a pinata that was
crazy that was a great uh it was sorry
sorry oh no it's just crazy the [ __ ]
uh
they just these guys just get hit and
they're just like all right like i got
hit once in high school and my elbow i
didn't feel this whole nerve for like
two weeks
like that [ __ ] sucks yeah i'm and i
was like i didn't handle it well at all
just like ah
ah [ __ ] oh my coach like dude shake it
off like ah [ __ ] you
yeah never again you could hit a home
run
do what you think you could hit home run
no no no no are you kidding me i went to
the batting cages recently was at arcade
and sherman oaks and i went there and
it's like it's pretty [ __ ] fun oh
bank is great if you love a batting case
bill burger
the pit he threw the pitch out uh oh
yeah he threw a good pitch did he do his
show yet at uh not yet is it fenway yeah
how cool is that comic a little fluffy
did uh dodgers
stadium bird took over the the
commentating booth and was killed that
was [ __ ] amazing i saw the clip of
that holy [ __ ] great dream do you ever
see the clip of seinfeld crazy norman
during a mets game yeah i mean every
comic i haven't seen that
no come on you must have a social media
manager it was cool it was seeing
seinfeld with uh jordan remember that in
the jordan dodge background i wouldn't
do this when he's talking about the
plays at the height of seinfeld too i
know the two heights that's like two
jordans oh yeah
the best i love that 90s [ __ ] was like
everybody in the country was in on all
that now it's it's splintered right
right
it's good for comics like us but it's
like yeah it is weird that the country
is not all watching this like water
cooler conversations yeah they don't
even have water coolers anymore right
everyone brings their bottle
everything's hilarious yeah everyone's
watching something different so there's
no real common thread other than maybe
the finals or
but like the amber heard trial was like
we're all back on something that's kind
of fun i mean it sucks for them but yeah
it's fun it's something shitty like back
in the day it was the sopranos you're
like did you see the soprano right now
it's like did you see these two real
people's lives yes fall apart exactly
can you imagine if the oj trial was on
twitter
oh that would have been the craziest
[ __ ] ever oh my god it's black twitter
would have gone nuts
i like the broncos back though have you
seen that yeah ford is like enough time
has passed
let's bring it back
wow
that was a great old melanie joke he's
like isn't it crazy this guy did
something so bad they took a type of car
away like a match if i did something
[ __ ] up like no more camry wow great
great
uh i'll tell you that 30 for 30 on oj
probably the best one ever i mean
[ __ ] like a work of art that guy ezra
edelman who's like oh he's great yeah
i'm an old filmmaker i haven't seen that
one oh dude it's like five or six parts
probably but it's it's worth it all
you're right okay yeah i remember it now
it actually covered race relations in
los angeles like you thought it was just
going to be about the oj trial but it
kind of did a deep dive in where we were
in history oh it was all in the american
dream
his pressure about being a black guy in
like the late 60s 70s
i mean so much i mean then like there's
guys like should he have felt that
pressure to have to be right and
outspoken i mean because i don't think
you have to but i mean then the guys
like creamy abdul jabbar and bill
russell were we're doing so much i mean
it's it's
it asks a lot of [ __ ] up questions
it's amazing yeah i mean they did a mini
series about on fx too with cuba
gooding
junior junior thank you
or kuba
i don't know maybe
i think it's kuba i would always say
cuba but maybe i'm wrong yeah i always
say cuba too but it's probably kuba yeah
you don't say scuba diving
just saying
all right what were you talking about i
don't know
all right oj
no i never saw those mini those mini
series always kind of bugged me a little
bit
like they did like the patty hearst one
i'm like i just want to watch the dock
or i want to i know yeah i don't you
know like the dock feels like less
creative liberties when you see travolta
in a wig you're like i don't know how
much of this is
that's true tanya harding tanya was good
but it is you can't beat a doc oh
travolta is like let's write in a
masseus scene you're like what are you
talking about
what was the other one
schwimmer came to the store one time
really yeah was he was he sad
he just had the sad size
rachel was he cool
that was pretty good you're on a break
the thing with the store is
it's low key it's not like the factory
where it's super well lit and you're
kind of there to be seen like sometimes
bieber will go to the factory but the
store is dark it's it's you know
uh not super well i saw bieber at the
factory he was only half laughing him i
said it was pretty [ __ ] up
timely dude timely we've all taken it
um so he just came he was in the back
and then he slipped out and got into a i
was in like a suburban and bounced i was
there once and they were like tarantino
was here last night i was like ah he's
in my thing did you see what he's in
there yeah yeah yeah
it was just so cool like uh i think it's
after the main room set so i'm coming
through and he happened to be in the
crowd and he was like i wanna talk to
the cool guy so he caught myself what
you're the cool guy i'm the cool guy
um and i got to talk to tarantino and he
hung out the whole night he was like i
need a guy in my new movie it's too bad
you're not ethnic at all it's just
it's too bad you're in this ethnic no
man's land
otherwise i could have cast you you know
hassan
number
damn that's why what'd he say to you
just it was surreal man like uh
are you a huge tarantino guy yeah i love
his movies i love him so he was like i
want to talk to the cool guy and he's
like oh yeah that was great were talking
i think he was saying
he was watching the comedy store
documentary and he used to come to the
comedy store all the time like in his
20s
and uh he dated margaret cho back in the
day right oh did he i think so
but he was talking about how
he saw kennison and stuff yeah during
the late night spot and then also like
dice yeah um
yeah and he just said i was watching the
comedy store documentary and i missed
the place and i wanted to come back he
lives in like tel aviv now yeah yeah
yeah so his wife is in israel he said he
had to go to like a bomb shelter during
the bombings that's crazy
yeah dude that uh
that's crazy he's obsessed with like
that late 70s yes late 60s early 70s
film period which is like the best
obviously but like i mean i loved his
last movie the uh the hollywood was
great yeah i loved it but how cool is
that sometimes we're so
microscopic and we do we we just like
okay what's my bit blah blah and you
forget that these other art forms
appreciate what you do on a different
level because you're too close to it
like like you doing joker it's [ __ ]
like awesome it's so awesome
yeah but it's just a testament to you
working on your craft and then somebody
else recognizing what you're doing right
and todd phillips being just like a cool
guy
he's like a cool dude who likes comedy
the way we probably like movies you know
totally but there is this mutual
adoration for different art forms where
like portugal the man would come to the
comedy store all the time and they were
so we got to like talk to them and they
would come by and
you're not you're just like working on
your set but you don't know who's in the
crowd and you're like oh what you do is
so much better than what i do yeah yeah
so it's so cool when there's that
crossover i love that it was a kevin
hart special once and at one point he
does a joke and he looks down in the
crowd and shacks in the front like
and i was like that's amazing shaq's in
the front row but that happens i saw a
sebastian special seinfeld his wife on
the front row so you're like i love when
the big names come out i'm like hey can
we not sit jerry in eyesight for my
special please that would be my request
that's part can i not see one of the
legends of comedy
could you not put harvey weinstein right
oh you saw that one show that that comic
yelled at him for being out oh that was
crazy wait which special it wasn't
especially it was a clip
but some some comments yeah she's like
it's [ __ ] i mean it was pretty badass
she said that right i was here in new
york right yeah yeah
uh
i got to tell her fitzsimmons
fitzsimmons did a show at the comedy
store he said he was dying on stage
bombing the crowd was very sensitive or
something and he does one joker he goes
so aids is bad but you gotta admit
it's the best way
like [ __ ] to get aids it's about like
you know i can't remember the joke but
he's like out of all the diseases
that'll kill you at least you get to
[ __ ] and then die or something and he
said
the whole crowd turned on him and there
was one guy in the back going
ah
and it was tarantino
it was rock hudson
it was magic johnson
but yeah yeah that that's nice to hear
that tarantino's like
appreciates like
tarantino is such an artist i bet he
like appreciates seeing [ __ ] go south
like come on man like we as comics we
like watching great comics bomb
like it's almost more not like i'm
taking pleasure in it but more like how
how are they gonna handle it like i've
seen nutella deal with bad crowds and
you're like oh well this is like special
that they it's almost more interesting
to see crowds knock at david tells
genius yeah where i'm like oh you're
missing i see how great dave is yeah
comics see how great dave is but once in
a while you'll catch a crowd that like
just doesn't click with him and the way
he turns it's like [ __ ]
it's like when yoda just takes out the
lightsaber and stuff
you're like holy [ __ ] right exactly
i saw uh i'm such a comedy nerd then i
was on youtube one time and seinfeld was
at the comedy store in london i was like
let me check that out
it's not a great crowd and he you know
he said he's used to doing theaters and
you know adoration and all that and he
turns him around just with his he bring
he kicks it up a notch i'm not gonna say
he turns on him he's like what the [ __ ]
is with you [ __ ]
what's the deal with teeth you got bad
ones
yeah but he turned it around just like
he kicked it up a notch it was like oh
yeah this guy's a club comic from back
in the day he's a pro so it's fun to
watch one of my favorite moments ever is
on the rodney dangerfield dvd box set
where it's like all those amazing old
specials where it's like you know he's
introducing all these amazing young
comics i love that but there's one where
it's him old as [ __ ] in vegas and he
doesn't look great and he's kind of
bombing and they just kind of you could
see you're like [ __ ] is this dude lost
his fastball and then he just starts
hammering hammering one liner after one
liner and it gets to a point where after
a string of them he's killing the crowd
gives him a huge applause break and he
just goes i know a lot of [ __ ] jokes
it's like you just gotta swagger right
back it was like oh
you need to like kick into gear
sometimes because you go on autopilot
you're the celebrity or a big name
whatever so
he didn't seem like he went on autopilot
though rodney is like oh we could we
should do a patreon we just watched like
old rodney oh
still still killer i would want they
would have uh
evening the improv on hulu yeah so they
had this back catalog of all the evening
at the improvs and they have legends on
there but they were like three years
into stand-up wow so it like i would
watch martin lawrence or adam sandler
and they're you know i go at the improv
i'm there all the time to see that stage
and these legends on there and to see
them three years in it's kind of nice
because they look three years in yeah
yeah and they their jokes are three
years in and it's almost a nice reminder
that like oh everyone's on this journey
and not every stand-up is fully formed
until you get to whatever whenever that
is and it's different for everybody so
to see martin lawrence
do do good you know but like like a
three-year comic it was almost a nice
recalibration and inspiring right it's
huge oh okay it's just a process for
everybody no matter who you are and
we're lucky enough to have those videos
to watch like they just had to deliver
that they couldn't really look back they
look back on henny youngman or some [ __ ]
you know we can see all the process we
have all the carson sets you know yeah i
guess you had to watch like it's hard to
just study them probably maybe the
library or something had them i don't
know maybe yeah you have to go to the
paley center and just put on some weird
headphones
there's a homeless guy jerking off next
to you like you're not i don't want to
study these youtube psychos though that
somebody made like bill burr then the
now and it's like a
trajectory of like
1994 to whatever and he's got a full
head of hair he's got freckles he's cute
and then now at the end he's like these
[ __ ] jews or whatever it is that's a
good point fun to watch they did want a
ck bird as a there's a few of them
because even when they were famous if
you look at their early stuff it's
different than the way they are now yes
and uh it's just evolving no matter
where you are in your career you're not
the same
five or six years ago as you are now i
know that's a good thing i mean yeah
you're growing you're not if you are the
same that's a [ __ ] problem you
probably not seeing those people on tape
or dvd or whatever but i used to watch
those like larry miller sets
holy [ __ ] he was funny he was funny
great delivery great writing yeah like
those classic like jokes like the the
woman like you know you're breaking up
with her she's like you'll never meet
anyone like me again he goes yeah i
should hope not
i'm breaking up with you i mean his
drinking bit it's like eight minutes is
amazing and we've all had that moment
who who were your guys like dangerfield
attel brock like you know uh
i mean so many comics coming out who
else who are your dudes i mean norm and
seinfeld norm was huge seinfeld carlin i
loved greg gerald geraldo attell
louis i like stephen i love steven
wright i remember the first time hearing
steven wright being like this is blowing
my mind i mean burr blew my mind i mean
hedberg yeah i like different [ __ ] too i
remember seeing like i remember seeing
lily tomlin's searching signs of
intelligent life and i was like this is
like genius i was like this is crazy
yeah yeah carlin ellen's old ellen's
first album is incredible yeah
incredible
just club
great observational clean but you don't
notice it's clean
really good yeah that's the best when
there's a clean comic and you don't even
really know
because there is this kind of brand with
clean where you go i'm not gonna like it
it's gonna be too squeaky not edgy but
there's a way to be edgy with clean oh
my god oh yeah i remember seeing
watching a comic once i forgot who it
was with a guy book in the show i was
like ah you probably won't like her
she's she's like really clean i was like
laughing like what are you talking like
i just only like people that sound like
me it's like the opposite you want to
see something different from you yeah i
don't want to watch me i'm always amazed
at how many different ways there are to
be funny i know because you have your
style and your voice and your instrument
or whatever but then you see somebody do
something completely different
and you like love it be like oh i can
never do that and i love that [ __ ] oh my
god well i'm watching you do like these
big act outs i'm like i would not have
the balls i remember doing like tiny
little mics or tiny rooms and i was
watching this comic uh nick vader odd
who i think
nick is incredibly funny and i remember
watching him and just being in like awe
because he would do the craze there'd be
six people in the room and he'd be
selling it as if it was like a thousand
he'd be like sweating and i'd be dying
laughing yeah because
i mean like comics talk about like oh
that bit was brave i could give a [ __ ]
like
brave to me is like willing to look like
a buffoon
like that's brave right he has that bit
about uh
he's like yeah you go to the restaurant
they're like the catch of the day is uh
ahi tuna was in whatever and he's like
come on put some life into it if i was a
waiter i'd be like the catch of the day
there i was on the atlantic in a tugboat
alone and i was fighting with this thing
all day and night i shot in the face and
then i pulled into the boat then we fist
fought
it comes with rice
and i'm butchering it it was like way
more elaborate
yeah he i mean he is incredibly funny
nick vader incredible he did a i think a
fallon or seth meyers one of those
remember what the the set list jokes
brings up the set list and it rolls down
the stage it's so long it was like it
was wacky and original
he is he's just hilarious yeah yeah i
love that [ __ ] sometimes you forget as
stand-up comedians that uh
it kind of is a sandbox and you can make
it's a white canvas you can do whatever
you want like obviously you can tell
jokes and and that's like people expect
that
but sometimes it's fun if i have an
outside the box idea and it can kind of
turn the idea of like what stand-up is
on its head a little bit
we might be drunk as excited to welcome
our new sponsor
diet smoke
most of us have had a i don't think this
edible is working moment then 10 minutes
later you're on the couch and you can't
remember the word cat i've been there
edibles can hit you when you least
expect it and their dosage can be very
uncertain that's why when we need the
perfect medium high we hit our friends
at diet smoke for the delicious delta 8
thc gummies
each gummi is infused with 10 milligrams
of delta 8 thc derived from american
grown health hemp delta 8 is simply a
slightly less potent thc the high you
get with diet smoke is somewhere between
the chilledness of cbd and that classic
stone feeling you get with regular weed
plus diet smoke comes in two delicious
favorite flavors blue raspberry and
watermelon i've been taking this stuff
to go to bed you know me i can't get
high i go inward i hug my knees i think
of my dad i cry
this stuff is top-notch it's just what i
need it's like having a light beer yeah
you heard her dad does the same thing he
gets on his knees he thinks of you he
cries it's
all because this stuff right here that's
how i got in this mess mess
oh geez
it's legal in most states and
non-prescription just check diet smokes
website to see if they ship to your
state also their gummies are low in
sugar fat free and delish so when cbd
isn't enough and traditional thc is too
much enjoy the smooth buzz of diet smoke
that's diet smoke.com use promotional
code drunk for 20 off your order that's
dietsmoke.com promo code drunk 20 off as
a special offer diet smokes coupon code
can be used on every order so give it a
shot come back say like yeah i'm doing
this again 20 off again diet smokes
delta 8 thc gummies are not for use or
sale to people under the age of 21
please use responsibly diet smoke isn't
light
it's just right we might be drunk as
sponsored by better help online therapy
relationships take work a lot of us will
drop anything to go help someone we care
about we'll go out of our way to treat
other people well but how often do we
give ourselves the same treatment for me
working out or buying some new sneakers
is an investment in myself this month
betterhelp online therapy wants to
remind you to take care of your most
important relationship the one you have
with yourself where in therapy we go to
the same guy it's necessary clean out
the garbage your head has all these
horrible thoughts
splicing your childhood traumatic
experiences you're a wreck you're a mess
you need therapy get out the garbage
whether it's hitting the gym making time
for a haircut or even trying therapy
you're your greatest asset so invest
time and effort into yourself like you
do for other people tell them how better
help is online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with
your therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
maybe you got a weird boil on your face
or something you're weird you know you
don't want to see that you're all said
yep it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy and you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours give
it a try and see why over 2 million
people have used better help online
therapy we might be drunk is sponsored
by better help and listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
drunk that's b e t t e r h e l p dot com
slash drunk
you got to do this it's it's therapy
very important take care of yourself
it's gonna change your life you're here
it doesn't feel like it's a fun
existence to always have to be concerned
with like coming off as cool
right that seems like exhausting to me
yeah even like fashion i always think
about people who are on the bleeding
edge of fashion that just seems
exhausting yeah skipping meals uh
worrying about fittings but not only
that just sort of like what is the cool
clothes like
it's so much mental energy to be cool i
know you see julia fox with kanye and
all that i'm like does this look fun no
this doesn't look fun to me the clothes
don't look good either you know it's
funny she has that track you know that
one that came out where he's attacking
pete or whatever and he goes like
something about pete davidson she goes
who
and in my mind i'm like
more people know pete davidson than you
yeah
yeah i'm clueless but yeah i know i'm
with you then why are you writing the
song i know
it's it's all stupid but it's so funny
that kanye west has a diss track about a
comic we know i know it's wild it's
funny we know a guy [ __ ] kim
kardashian yeah and scarlett johansson
by the way that's true you're on the
other night to sell it colin jones great
guy great guy one of the nicest dudes
great dude great hair yeah great hair we
were talking about it we had uh it was
like misal and santino we were at this
italian place oh yeah and derosa was
there too we're talking about the penis
there's food derosa's thing
we're talking about the pete and kim
thing and we were just joking like how
funny is it that like a comic broke
kanye
you know what i mean like he was cool
with anything else but like a stand-up
comedian
that's so funny you don't hear about
that with like yakov
[Laughter]
comedy's like cool right now it's r it's
weird yeah you don't hear about like uh
like yakov smirnoff [ __ ] waka [ __ ]
with his ex-girlfriend you don't hear
about that that's a headline
dude
in soviet russia i guess you get your
dickwad
yeah i just think of comics like louis
anderson you know or drew carey or
something so it's funny that did you
know
i only i only knew like of him i never
got to like you know speak with him
personally and that's my one regret
because we're losing comedians you know
like every so often we'll lose a great
one like norm norm would come by the
store and wow i know adam you get really
well and like i wouldn't want to bother
norm but
i think moving on and
you know from this point forward i i
when i have those opportunities i want
to take them and say hello or be like
i'm a big fan because you may not have
that opportunity again and you take
these people for granted but life is
short and i wish that i would have you
know told norm that i'm a big fan and i
yeah i appreciate what he does and did
you speak with him at all or not just
maybe like a hello and just like a
pleasantry in the hallway but not enough
to be like
yeah like i'm a store you know like i
bet so many annoying comics bug norm and
then you're someone who i bet he would
have enjoyed talking to and you're like
i can't yeah you know but that's why he
would enjoy tugging it's just kind of
this catch-22 yeah i'm too much one-way
where i should have just been like hey
norm i'm a big fan and you know i like
what you do the same way yeah i met
larry david who's like
one of my heroes and i didn't even i i
saw him from across the room mark you
got to meet norm and i was like what's i
mean sorry larry david what's up larry
david he goes hey how are you and i i
didn't want to walk over because i knew
he would hate that
like just me going
all the way across the room and i just
couldn't do it to him and of course i
want to meet him of course i want to hug
him i want to get a photo with him but i
couldn't do it
but wouldn't you be happy if you had
that photo right now
of course of course i remember
i noticed that gary chandling followed
me on twitter and i was like i should dm
and just say like how much i love larry
sander and i just i never did it i was
just i took cowardly
yeah but don't you kind of wish like i
wish i just had like some i'm like some
acknowledgment that him follow me wasn't
an accident like he accidentally hit fox
you know
he's like he's like who who are you uh
no i mean larry sanders was my [ __ ] dude
and i think his old stand-up is killer i
love gary shandling but uh i love that
the dock the dock was great joey is
killing these docks man
promoting the doc the the carl and doc
and his new book and uh i mean i thought
the carl and doc was incredible too
we've talked about it but the shandling
one [ __ ] yeah glad he's taking the the
reigns of just making these killer ducks
about that tonight show story really
like [ __ ] with me what was that
where he did the tonight show and he
just collapsed because like he only
thought to the tonight show really like
he did he did the thing that he wanted
to do and like that happened what's
coming that's unleashed i can't i can't
make it past you
you collapsed in byron allen's arms
you go i've reached the summit so you
collapsed recently
thanks byron anyway
we'll be back
i heard you kissed a boy
she's like no special
there's my little tease
i was also a boy i was seven as well
yeah
yeah
i heard you wanted to go to mars
recently
so you know i [ __ ] with him i went on
this is an amazing norman story by the
way i went on and it's so cheesy look i
i don't want to [ __ ] on the guy because
he's you know doing the lord's work
whatever but and he's helped a lot of
comments yeah he's brilliant man you
know what it's easy to like dude but
yeah he's giving comics so many
opportunities and like he sees the
showbiz matrix and he's rich for a
reason like oh he's a smart guy smart
guy but i went on and i was like uh just
as a comic instinctively like this is
weird
this is so off uh inauthentic and our
whole thing is being authentic
so he was like so you gotta i hear you
have a dog and i was like no i don't
have a dog
and you can see his whole world is
collapsing he's like this is the format
we've done it for 40 years what the [ __ ]
are you doing that was all in his eyes i
was like nah i don't have a dog i hate
dogs i'm actually allergic it's like
temple of doom he just rips your [ __ ]
heart out
did he think you had a joke about dogs
yeah i wrote it down i wrote a dog joke
down i didn't do the best part of this
mark's even told this part they do a
group picture with everyone and mark is
doing this oh
yeah yeah that's in the group picture
only what the [ __ ] are you doing yeah so
i just couldn't do it it's the opposite
of comedy
it just felt wrong that that british
thing we did is kind of in this that's
the same in the same vein it felt kind
of comics unleashed yes yes
mark did it yeah well you got it because
you did it
when they were hitting me up to do it i
was like on the fence but then i saw you
were doing it and list was doing it
never agreed to something because mark
agreed to do it no that's what we've
learned yeah but no i'm like oh this
seems legit
yeah it was legit it just wasn't it was
a little different than the way they
pitched yeah so that's why it was kind
of a little
like we were doing homework in london i
thought i was going to be able to
explore and hang out there but you had
this giant packet and you were doing a
lot of your old material yeah so it was
kind of kind of high pressure oh yeah i
thought it was going to be a few like at
midnight jokes we had a meeting where
he's like are you doing a lot of writing
and i was like uh well i'm getting to it
he's like you have to write like they
they kind of were stirring with me like
you're you're bombing out there you have
to do more work and i was like okay okay
what after the first taping yeah yeah he
kind of yelled at me a little bit
uh cause like i saw the link sounds like
a horrible european vacation well it's
in a british accent so it's not as
abrasive you go oh okay i'm good at that
yeah but it was tough and uh i'm telling
my lady like i can't go to big ben i
have to write a pun about a book and a
meet
you know coming together
so that was hard yeah she wasn't playing
hopefully it'll
it'll cut together well because in those
british panel formats they shoot so you
know you're doomed when you're like
we'll fix this in the editing kind of
hopefully but the editing could be
horrible like i had a couple of riffs
and i was like yeah i was proud of that
i finally got to be myself but i'm sure
they'll cut that out yeah it's a weird
like that's very popular in london that
british panel show where comics are all
at like a table and there's little
categories and you say these gems and it
was us versus london no it wasn't the
thing where the market was so honestly
it was because the british kids were a
killer how many oh because that's their
jam that's what i'm saying that's like
their tonight show or it's culturally
panel shows they grew up with that and
that's like a big thing yeah in london
how many british people were on yours uh
just two but they were both ringers
assassins assassins yeah they would go
first like here's the question here's
the category and they would be ready and
they would have five five killer ones
and you'd have two okay ones and then
you'd do four bad ones and those would
bomb but theirs would hit i mean it was
it was ugly they were getting applause
nothing when you open with what you
think is your winner and then you're
like well here come the [ __ ] duds
yeah exactly yeah but the the tape night
was three hours and they cut it down in
22 minutes so there'll be some gold
that's true that's true yeah they shoot
super fat damn yeah by the way these
[ __ ] drinks are phenomenal yeah two
i'm good no no we got to save some of
this for tomorrow you won't wanna
yeah give it one he needs one save some
for uh segura though too
oh
yeah we got we want everyone to try the
bodega cat until we get the full case
yeah are we just gonna drink bodega cat
every episode of this for a while i
think we do i think i think this just
becomes the bodega cat pod we've almost
killed a bottle in one house why not
no you like it you're a professional bar
guy and you like it
all right i think it's gonna dazzle some
people i think we gotta we got a winner
here i want to have my own malt liquor
i'm gonna go the other direction
like you guys can do the high shelf
stuff i'm gonna be a man of the people
once again it's not epic enough
that would really fly off the shelf yeah
i just have like a hookah coal that i'm
selling
[Laughter]
is it is it tempting to lean in to the
afghan no because like i don't even
think that way my brain my brain isn't
even uh it's not even integrity i just
like i
real comments i guess but i i mean
whatever strikes me is funny just
doesn't happen to lean that way and if
you're an observational i'm an
observational guy you have great jokes
about uber like you'll do jokes about
[ __ ] that's like the everyday experience
and like that's kind of how mark and i
write i think the issue is sometimes
when we're all observational it's like
[ __ ] has this been done today oh yeah
that's the issue rebuilding your [ __ ]
you want to make sure you have a good
angle yeah but i think you do it for
long enough you realize
because i think when i first started
comedy and a joke works it seems so
fleeting like will i be able to do it
again
but over time you you just kind of
accept this truth that
i i'm i'm wire different yeah i see the
world different i'll let you know when i
get there i'm at the you're not there
yet where i'm like i'm [ __ ] no but
from the outside looking in you do see
the world different so yeah i feel a
little [ __ ] right now
i'll let you know and everyone has that
imposter syndrome and that like everyone
will always have a shade of it but i
think there's this thing that happens
when you do comedy for long enough where
you just realize
oh i perceive the world a little
differently than so even if you're
talking about a well-tread topic your
angle is going to be different than
anybody else's angle because you're sam
yeah get to work
sure i really gotta get to work but this
[ __ ] but where are we going that's
the other thing we worry about comedy
and i'm i'm i should take my own advice
but we're not going anywhere you just
put out a special both of you guys doing
specials it's like
five years to go by there'll be another
one yeah and another one you know we're
we're in this for the long game
yeah and it's like i really am having
fun i was texting mark the other day you
know he's texting me after my special
and he's like you know just being
supportive you know your friends are
supportive and i said hey you know uh
i'm grateful i really am like you know
you have good friends a good family
i like where my career is at like i'm
kind of like i'm trying to just enjoy my
life right now and just you know just
did the beacon he just did a letter the
letterman thing is [ __ ] amazing this
guy's rolling yeah yeah oh you guys as
well i mean [ __ ] you and and it's cool
it's life is all right right now you
know like this is fun this is work
because i'm drinking with you yes i'm
drinking with people i enjoy and this is
a [ __ ] job yeah sometimes you have to
remind yourself of that because you'll
hop on instagram when you wake up and
yeah i i haven't glow i know you have to
remind yourself this is like a big
moment for me where i realize
you can't do all the cool things
no one can do all the cool things like
you might look at some stuff and you go
oh that looks cool that looks cool but
it's not a multiverse where you get to
do every [ __ ] thing in the world
you're doing cool [ __ ] that people envy
you're doing cool [ __ ] that people envy
like i'm doing cool [ __ ] you can't do it
all right yeah and also you i don't want
to do it all yeah you don't want to do
it all i'm already exhausted yeah hey i
came here hungover i'm not like you know
and think we have the internet at our
fingertips i hate the internet because
it's so mean and so toxic and whatever
but
i mean just think how much more you can
do now like my parents are like you're
doing this you do you flew here are you
tired i'm like nah i'm doing the road
like you flew to indianapolis and then
you're going back on sunday i mean
you're taking a break right i'm like i
got a spot at the seller like you have a
spot tonight oh my god like i like this
though i like it i want to live i want
to pack as much in i look at life as
fleeting i'm not gonna die you do have
to reset something of course
i do the same thing where i like i land
and i go to the cellar and i'm like i
needed it to take a night like somebody
i guess that because you also need to
live like you're talking about top gun
i'm like i haven't got do i haven't been
to i used to go to the movie theater
like once a week that's true i haven't
been this is the last movie i saw in the
theater 1918.
no it was 1917 1917. did you see the the
sequel
it was one year later you've been to the
theater since 1918 holy [ __ ] i haven't
that's a great movie to see in the
theater by the way
yeah i mean [ __ ] incredible but
that's the last time i saw a movie in
the theater and that was like three
years ago we're busy we're we're lucky
that we're lucky we do stand up and our
scenery is changing all the time i had
this writing job for about a year year
and a half what are we riding on uh it's
not uh united states is a valve that
chuck lowery show two oh nice yeah it's
okay you know yeah it's interesting when
you write is he cool chuckler he you
know what's interesting is we operate in
the world of stand-up and and we're all
like hip and savvy and think we're on
the cutting edge of comedy and [ __ ] and
it's easy to be like oh chuck laurie
shows or whatever it's not my cup it's
not like a cool thing let's say
but when he would come into the room for
rewrites
there is a brilliance no to what he
imagined two and a half men from the
biggest shows of all time two and a half
man big bang theory mike and molly
did all those wow he he prints money the
guy
is who he is for a reason and it was
very cool
to
to see that in person because it's easy
to be like that's over here that's a
different thing than what i'm doing but
when he would come in he sees
the he's a nice guy
nice enough like people yeah he's a nice
guy but he is just so busy and so rich
that he doesn't have the time
to like
kid gloves yeah yeah exactly you know
what i mean because his time is very
very valuable yeah so i understood it um
do you like the writer's room experience
i mean you're such a comic i feel like
you would hate it yeah exactly so i'm it
came during the pandemic so it was cool
to have that when the world shut down
and we couldn't really go on stage and
because i i never tried to get staffed
when i was a comic because i love stand
up and acting and i love the [ __ ]
changing all the time but this came it
was easy they were the eps were fans of
of me and they just offered it to me
and i was like yeah cool there's nothing
you know the world shut down and i got
to learn a bunch of stuff but after
doing it that long i kind of realized
i can't it felt like boeing because i
used to work at boeing
yeah yeah so it felt like
joke boeing whoa
joey joey
you're at a conference table for 10
hours every day you have an office
there's a break room
so it kind of it's not you i mean
nightmare i mean you talk about acting
and stuff i mean you were in that tina
fey movie right yeah foxtrot how did
that happen that was just auditioning
yeah you gotta i've never gotten
anything off an audition in my life
really have you not one any acting thing
i've gotten they've been like yeah like
you just come in dude that but honestly
that is where it's at
anything that i've booked just off of an
audition
as i look back on it i'm like whoa
that's [ __ ] insane yeah the eyes to
not have yeah the odds are so small to
have no
nepotism dude [ __ ] yeah
nothing was tina fey cool yeah she was
super nice martin freeman was really
cool too he's a great actor great actor
super nice we had t alfred molina so
nice oh he's good that dude always
delivered dude
i'm not a huge superhero movie guy but
spiderman too he's phenomenal yeah he's
great margot robbie was in it too so the
thing is i think she was getting ready
for um birds of prey or or maybe that's
a good movie no it was earlier than that
bruised prey is a salad superhero this
was the first suicide squad she was
getting ready for that okay so she had
suicide squad the first one
so she was trying to get fit and the
personal she was like kind of ducking
the personal trainer
so me and the personal trainer became
she if she's ducking a personal trainer
what shot do we have i know right
you think i'm going to [ __ ] show up
she's naturally gifted she's like
beautiful yeah she doesn't need the
personal trainer so hot and wolf of wall
street
jesus christ
but me and the trainer became good
friends and we were just like hanging
around new mexico for like a month
so you were there for a while yeah
well that's the thing with hollywood is
sometimes you'll shoot a movie and they
want you there for a month even though
you only have three shoot days total
that's another you're going crazy there
without kind of going bonkers i'm not
getting it in new mexico you don't
you don't get up i think marin started
there yeah
what uh
yeah
do you any memories from working with
tina fey like any anymore she was nice
enough you know it was around that time
period when the the blue dress yellow
dress thing was happening remember a
while ago it was a little while ago yeah
and there was a there was a cast dinner
so i met lauren because i think it was a
broadway video so i met lauren michaels
did you ever want to do snl yeah that's
why i got in the stand up i mean he's
probably you're built for now you're
built for my best friend is on it
aristotle so he was part of
yeah so your uncle no i know
but it's one of those things coming to
new york man
when you're younger you have these
idealized versions of what it is but
then you get older and you you go would
you move to new york ever for us
if i had a job but i don't have this
rope like it's fun i like visiting this
has been fantastic yeah but i don't know
if it like speaks to my soul like i
gotta live out here regardless sure i
get that you can't tell me l.a speaks to
your soul la doesn't speak to my soul
but it's
i like space i like my car i like my
music no i hear that here it's your
folks are in seattle yeah so it's easy
to fly up and see them i get that here
your car is like your air pods
right people put the headphones in is
their slight barrier to everybody else
yes because there's no physical barrier
so you need to put the headphones oh
that's good this is the physical barrier
you're in the subway back the [ __ ] off
yeah it's a lot of that there's no yeah
there's nothing i love having people
around that i don't have to talk to
but i like that they're there i feel the
same way that was a part of the carl and
doc i really related to where he was
like he needed his friends around but
didn't want to speak to them i was like
oh my god that's what i do i just i'm
like i might come over and then my
friends are saying i'm like
yeah it's like having the tv on
yeah right it's like when you leave the
radio on for the dog oh my god well i
i need noise too on the road i'll leave
the tv on
i just want noise
same where'd you grow up where did you
go i'm in the from the city you're from
new york yeah and you he's he's normal
what about you i'm from new orleans ah
this is crazy so i've known your stuff
for so long and i feel like i know you
same here dude but like we've never
actually sat down and talked i know we
talked a little bit in the hallway
i'm always so happy when you come by the
store because i never get to see you
guys back at you i mean
always good to see you you know but yeah
but it's like it's funny like
when do you have your first conversation
a podcast that's a big part of why we do
this we get to
how often do you get to really talk with
because you know we're all socially
awkward and on them on the run
and you know
doing sets even on the run
comedy club you're not really able to
talk you're like oh i'm on in two
minutes sorry yeah we're gonna talk
about movies too on the road but people
you must see movies on the road i feel
guilty wasting those weekends i feel
like i have to be productive during the
day on the road like i'll go get a bite
or something but i want to have
something new to say at those shows
totally and if i'm going to the movies i
just like but then i'm like when do you
go to the movie i love going to the
movies
we have less time i mean
podcasting is really taking it takes
hours and hours and then you got to
write you got to tweet you got to post
clips you got to do stand up it's it's
sometimes i envy
old hollywood
where you could be humphrey bogart and
you do a film and people don't die at
like 58 though that's shitty he died
young and then sinatra was like nursing
him when he was dying and then he
totally banged lauren mccall
they were boys yeah i mean there was a
cool thing where people only knew you
through your art i know you did i
messaged so i would love for that i know
but nowadays accessibility is the new
mystique
i don't know if that's true no the only
person who could do mystique is
who's the cobbler the actor chandler no
isn't he the cobbler
he's in that like phantom thread what's
up bro daniel day-lewis yes
he's like the last guy who they will
allow this took a toll it [ __ ] it he
retired young i mean he'll be back
yeah but no one's asking daniel
day-lewis to live-tweet the movie
can you imagine daniel that's true
daniel can you tweet this can you do an
ig live he just answers this daniel
plainview shut the [ __ ] up
jesus i will drink your milkshake from
five guys
dude you know uh
i don't know i'm with you i love old
hollywood [ __ ] and i love mark and i
talk about movies on this podcast
non-stop we're obsessed with like
old-timey like old nicholson [ __ ] and
like how cool that time period was and
that era of like robert evans and yeah
and nicholson you see that the kid stays
in the picture
i read the book i heard the docs
yeah i gotta watch he's robert evans was
just [ __ ] hilarious that's one of the
best docs one of the cool i gotta watch
the doc he's a legend yeah just him on
the phone and he's giving an interview
about him on a phone call and he still
says the slurs he's like tell that
[ __ ] polock i won't work for that
amount of money i got the best cakes in
hollywood over here jesus christ you're
saying this
in a in an interview i love one of the
stories about him arguing with uh the
agent of faye dunaway trying they were
like friends but they hated each other
but it was at old hollywood like i like
you but go [ __ ] yourself
and she was trying to get faye dunaway's
money up for chinatown he was like go
[ __ ] yourself we got all we got jane
fonda interested you can go [ __ ] eat
[ __ ] and then like the next day he's
like this is the lowest this is the only
money we'll do it was like wait she's
like if i take that money to fade
dunaway she'll fire me and she'll be
right he's like [ __ ] you that's the
offer and then and then the next day
she's like
all right you're gonna be nuts but faye
dunaway took it and he goes i never made
jane fonda an offer i was wrong you know
so it's like all this [ __ ] and all
these exactly i loved it he's the kind
of guy who wears a crazy suit and he's
eating he's eating dinner at lunch with
the uh or eating lunch with the [ __ ]
napkin in his shirt you know he's all in
he's got a phone on one arm on his
shoulder look at him he's by the way
he's by the pool
you got to see this doc oh dude he was
uh he's a legend
those the movies he made were [ __ ] i
mean godfather rosemary's baby was a
risk and he went for it but those days
are over now it's where i got to talk
every day for a lot of reasons
yeah i mean you're right though
hollywood had mystique but now
celebrities are completely
uh
out of touch it's like when you watch
the odd videos
it's not cool i mean yeah they used to
be cool yeah jim carrey nailed it when
he said like we used to be the cool club
and we're not like yeah dude i mean you
watch the oscars now and you're like
give us a [ __ ] i mean like but donna's
doing this [ __ ] yeah bathtub you're like
well i think the pandemic revealed that
a lot of actors need writers because
yeah hilarious
we worship actors in this country and
it's like man we should be worshiping
writers a little more like writers are
cooler to me honestly
i always
once you become a writer on the show you
kind of see this this difference between
the actors and the writers they're two
different worlds they make the same
thing but they're it's it's different
lunch tables right oh yeah and whenever
it comes to a popular show a lot of
times people would try to ask the actor
and be like so what happens in season
three do you have any spoilers for us
yeah and i always and the actors are
like oh i can't really say if you dm'd
any of the writers and said what goes on
in season three they would tell you
everything
because they're just so excited anybody
even knows who they are right
but this is where you're both you're
both that's what i'm saying i was
visiting i was visiting with the writing
you know it was cool i learned a lot um
but i think what's cool about doing
those things is you learn what you want
out of life and and what your speed is
yeah and i like that i was able to lay
down some writing track sure but i think
i just i i love how okay we're doing a
gig here in london and then we're doing
a show
uh you know jersey or something just
your scenery is changing all the time
yes i just knew i couldn't be in the in
a room for no way you blinking it's ten
years later exactly exactly and you get
your nice lunch and the pay is good and
you know you have your coffee there but
i'd rather be living
out moving i like not knowing i've
learned to love the road i really have
like it's a sickness but when you go
it's funny people like every week i'm
like that's kind of the only way i can
do it it's almost like painful to take
two weeks off yeah and then just go on
the road like if i'm out there every
week i'm like man it's part of my week
yeah and also i think we we did it hard
like in my 20s i went hard i mean i
drank every night i tried to get laid
all the time and all this [ __ ] and like
now i'm on the road and you ever ever
stay in new york or la on a saturday and
everybody's [ __ ] up
yeah she's falling off the side i'm
disciplined on the road in new york city
i'm like my friends are hitting me up
like meet me at this bar exactly i'm
[ __ ] wasted exactly it's built for
alcoholism though that's the thing about
new york you know it is just with the
subway 4 a.m it really is right yeah the
pizza in london when we were in london
everyone's just in suits the culture the
pub culture i was just telling
everyone's off of work and they're
drinking pints that's just what you do
but then at nine o'clock the city's dead
dropping me off try to get food after
take dude it was crazy dude i was trying
to eat dinner and everything closes
after nine i know i know i'd have to get
a room service which was eight million
dollars
these are so good you won't you want one
there did he get one he was gonna go
right now all right
peters you're good yeah
people are uh oh yeah we've gone along
sorry yeah oh people are kind of
whatever about the show you know like my
standup is very different than what the
sitcom is you kind of learn to be a team
player as well just yeah i'll add
whatever i can to the team project
you're just a pl you're like a role
player right so
like this show is different than what i
do stand-up wise you know yeah yeah sure
you ever like you ever think of a really
killer joke and you're like i ain't
giving it to this [ __ ]
no cause they're like two different
things i don't think there's something
so fire that i would do that i'm like oh
this would be great for the show
and that's the thing about writing um
for tv shows it's a little more
manufactured because you have these list
of characters and you know what sets you
have to use like the living room um
it's not for like two seasons
but when you write for sitcoms what
actors are on
uh hank from breaking bad was on it
parker young
pharah man that [ __ ] character i'm
breaking bad amazing one of the most
heartbreaking because
you watch that show and out of the gate
you're like this cheesy guy and then by
the end you're like he's the only decent
one you know
i don't know so i'm in one episode of
this like it was cool they let all right
they let me yeah be in one of the
episodes and i i had some scenes with
hank you know yeah dean norris d norris
nice guy great guy and so we're around
this dinner table and i just i told him
i go gattica is one of my favorite
movies in the world
and he's like oh thanks man yeah and i
like that because i think that's a deep
cut he probably doesn't get gattaca that
much yes but gattaca speaks to my soul
yeah i just love that movie interesting
there's something i know
i'm saying i loved your siso especially
exactly i'll start crying i'll start
crying like oh [ __ ] you
you put up with the pay wall
you knew how to download
cso but it's good you did it you got to
see what the world is like of writing
and uh you realize it's not for you it's
all bricks you're just building some
bricks
and you uh even if you do something and
you realize okay maybe i don't want to
do that in the future at least you know
now but don't you see i mean you worked
on tv we just did this show in london tv
now after doing like youtube specials
and our own [ __ ] and clips and whatever
podcast like this
you realize how wasted how much of a
waste of time half that [ __ ] is with
network well they're waiting around
right there's an in-office authenticity
to it yeah i'm not saying everything
should be this loose obviously i
appreciate a great movie like we talk
about how much we love the worst person
in the world what a great movie sure but
i bet that felt independent
i agree that's what i'm saying like this
this london show there's a warm-up guy
give me a big laugh now give me a
smaller give me a
like what are we doing the lights the
crew we gotta take off okay union rules
we all gotta go to lunch now and you're
like we could have knocked this out in
an hour you know we're here for 10 hours
you're right it feels like tv old tv
feels like buckshot
and this [ __ ] feels like a sniper there
you go right
because you get to be funny right but
uh within within reason
yeah yeah yeah i mean look at conan
conan had a fun late night show we all
loved it we all loved conan and now he
just said [ __ ] that i'll do a podcast
they'll get the same interview they'll
get the same me maybe a little better me
more authentic me yeah and it's zero
camera zero production zero makeup zero
i still love there's something i loved
about doing letterman though where i'm
like i'm doing this for an audience like
there's something that makes you turn
your [ __ ] on when there's an audience in
the room
you know there's no audience for the
conan's podcast that's what i mean like
conan is so quick and funny and he's
such a master at not just being an
interviewer but like knowing his role in
the interview like is the guy a dud is
the person to dud he'll be funny yeah
he's the person nor macdonald or bill
burr he'll sit back and be the straight
man you're right like there's something
to that that's an art agreement and i
really do doing the letterman thing i
was kind of like wow this is what it
would have been like to be a comic in
like the 80s and like yeah i kind of
wish that's what i was because i loved
doing an interview and just
having to be like riff jokes and be
funny and like i love this but i love
that you're like you're in and out like
it's quick it's like for sure
totally it is no i love an audience i
agree but
i think a lot of it is is unnecessary
with with tv well the amount of [ __ ]
people want now is kind of interesting
like i i mean
it's fine i guess you know those shows
were every night and podcasts we do once
a week but like yeah you know i mean
that's a full-time job yeah oh yeah for
sure
and just like the coveted stuff and the
makeup the covert shit's exhausting well
brutal and it's hypocritical because
it's like you're not going to require
mass on planes but then you force this
to take a test to get back in the
country there's no consistency with it
yeah so just be a little [ __ ]
consistent be nice i don't want to do
any i did toronto i don't want to do any
more foreign gigs
because i the idea of just testing
positive and being stuck there for 10
[ __ ] days
makes me crazy i'm like i'll stick to
doing it's hard enough to do gigs
domestically right and then when you
throw in these covered like okay i got
to get a pcr test and soda stuck in
winnipeg
you know it was stuck in winnipeg for 10
days really yeah dan soder and then you
know veda and i gary vito when we do
toronto second we land we have to go
find a covet test because we were there
for one night i'm like yeah i don't
that's not how i want to do this sucks
yeah
they should provide you with a covet
test if you're doing the gig but yeah
you know coveted kind of uh it pulled
the veneer off of these institutions
because when like fallon was doing
tonight's show at his place
then you didn't have the fancy sets you
didn't have the suits you didn't have
the gloss you go oh you're no better
than a youtuber at this point it really
leveled the playing field you got that
right yeah so that was and i think
uh late night post covid feels
more artificial way more it feels faker
and i still enjoy doing it sure but
you're 100 right because we saw we saw
the strings yes we saw it without gloss
right so now it's more of a relic of we
show you without makeup yeah a little
bit like when you see trevor going but
we know we know what you really look
like
yeah yeah no in the living room he had
like a little like a five o'clock shadow
he's wearing sweatpants
yeah during covid everyone had the same
tools right good point good point i mean
we all saw the imagine video or the
black and white whatever video where
they're like i've learned a lot i've
been educated you're like oh god jesus a
lot of people were like you didn't know
black people existed before this year
yeah this is the first year jesus is
like when black panther or crazy rich
asians does good and then hollywood's
like oh people
races want to see themselves like this
like this is a [ __ ] revelation that
people that black people want to see
black panther or asians want to see it's
not even asians it's just people want to
see a good movie regardless
representation's good wow i didn't know
yeah i mean it's uh also you know i
think about it is [ __ ] chadwick
boseman just being sick as [ __ ] doing
those movies poor poor bastard yeah such
a such a cool dude he seemed like i know
why'd i say that like yoda such a cool
man he seemed like
well that's not penicillin
no but he was you know to be that sick
is like
that's pretty amazing to be sick and to
still plow through and we're talking
about those schedules the way they just
drag everything out like that dude was
there probably long last days oh yeah
never to and we live in this victim
culture too and to not even use it then
i mean he could have gotten out of
everything i can't go to your party
cancer
sorry you can't do it
and he still did it
can't go to the red carpet cancer
although you know it'd be a cool move is
to just be like i can't make it they're
like why not like i just can't and then
you die a few years later and they're
they're [ __ ] talking to you for years
then they're like oh no yes i've been
trashing that guy for years
make them feel like [ __ ] i'm doing that
now with monkey pucks
it's coming oh you [ __ ] me that
means i have it god damn it all right
happy pride happy pride
[Music]
is the big thing so it's called hat
trick it's on my youtube he-man or
youtube.com or i'll chop it up for clips
on ig you know it's every clip i've seen
is killer i haven't seen the full
special yet i'm excited to watch it
thanks raheem's a great comic we highly
recommend it means a lot coming from you
guys you know because like i really
respect you and especially when
you were sort of pioneers of this new
way of doing things it was very cool
there were others before us i know like
adults
like joe and you guys but you guys are
definitely at the forefront of this new
thing that's happening in stand-up so as
someone who kind of felt overlooked by
traditional hollywood and the industry
i had a vested interest in in you guys
doing what you're doing and
it's almost like someone breaking a
four-minute mile you go oh cool like
it's possible
so
yeah i've you know i've always been a
fan from afar and it's cool to be out
here and be on this back and kind of be
in the same world we like you yeah but
don't put it back on us
yeah if you just type in comedy store
hat trick the special will come up take
a look at it follow me on ig um
and i'll be building the new hour around
la but i'll i'll try to get a tour
together maybe in the fall all right
yeah beautiful
all right well check him out we support
we're fans we like
uh all kinds of dates coming up i don't
know when this comes out keep going uh
uh
yeah a bunch of doing the fully loaded
tour with bert then uh
oh boy you gotta go show all dates we
got a big announcement uh with with more
we got doing the wilbur doing the
neptune in seattle hey hey come open if
you want oh man i don't know if that's
weird to have no not at all man but i
love going home we'd love to have you
and uh
portland i'm doing vancouver toronto
uh some other [ __ ] houston improv san
antonio
lol comedy off broadway and lexington
comedy at broadway's underrated good
club you got to play there it's actually
where is it
in kentucky
it's epic it's like the room is magical
it's great it's old someone's just
filming a special guy that's great too
all these rooms are great providence oh
yeah i got uh what do i have coming up
uh cleveland uh maybe there's next week
houston west palm beach buffalo san jose
uh pittsburgh or homestead apparently
oof
uh dania beach no it is good i've been
there i'm the reason comics can't do
morning radio there anymore thank you no
morning tv
i call it the ceo morning show you're
like carl and dude
lots of other gigs come in you know la
irvine um
louisville lexington
uh
[ __ ] dude i'm everywhere it's coming up
fort wayne uh
i don't know it'll be up soon
doing a lot of fun stuff coming up i
think it's monster energy tour so
they're they have the dates i forgot the
my own [ __ ] dates
but uh same we've been drinking we've
been drinking we we might be drunk yeah
we might be drunk potted uh i am it's
not a mighty i am yeah
we might be drunk we might be
drunkpod.com if you want our cool merch
bodega cat's on the way beard you we
love you yeah thank you everybody we're
grateful for the new studio this is
awesome
uh
you know we'll see on the road and uh
the patreon too if you want to get on
that but uh give out the website we
might be drunkpod.com yeah send us rex
peeves questions and uh yeah get on the
patreon and get a get a glass for
christ's sake we're having a good time
definitely check out faheem special he's
a great comic
[Music]
i've had a little too much
naked samuel is feeling
dangerous i'm out to lunch here in new
orleans this woman doesn't look like i
remember her and i get down in the same
way
we might
true
[Music]